your money is being confiscated I'm  about to tell you five ways in which  governments all around the world are  confiscating your money and you don't  even realize number one and the most  obvious is increasing taxation number  two is inflation while everybody spent  the last two years arguing about sex  race and gender central banks printed  unprecedented amounts of money as a  result the money sitting in your pocket  has drastically devalued number three  actual confiscation take a look at  Lebanon and take a look at Cyprus number  four your funds are actually being  frozen for holding the incorrect opinion  take a look at Canada and number three  Central Bank digital currencies which  are coming very soon so when you hold  the incorrect opinion your social credit  score will plummet take a look at China  how to combat this well that is exactly  what my content is dedicated to so hit  the follow button to stay up to date